the most important thing  uh  aside from the things i've talked about  already is it's really who you associate  with you want to associate with people  that are better than you are i mean  basically you'll go in the direction of  the people that you associate with and  and you want to have the right heroes uh  you want people  if you want to emulate somebody you  better pick very carefully who you want  to emulate and  and when  obviously you can't pick your parents uh  they're gonna have an enormous influence  on you but you don't get a choice on  that but you get choices as you go down  the line and you  who you uh  who you admire who you  who you want to copy and the most  important for most people in terms of  that decision is their spouse it's also  important in terms of a partner in  business with a partner in life is  the most important you want to pick a  spouse that's  better than you